hi guys how's it going happy holidays
this is a holiday edition of ask IJ have
any holiday clothes like a cool flame oh
it's kind of festive right now let's
give these questions I was trying to
strategically choose some festive
questions so starting off with this
first one
Ryan Minaj I don't believe that's your
last name wanna see a birth certificate
I'd already made a Star Wars Christmas
tree video but there have been some new
additions to the Christmas tree Millie
moppet ones know if I've ever eaten wait
no when was wait what when did I last
eat a chocolate waffle I've never had a
chocolate waffle feel like my life is
just not complete our dick spinach means
me argot I did try to go back to school
from first grade what's my reaction ah
oh no
Katelyn let's know what my favorite
Christmas movie is I know this is gonna
be really really hard to believe for
many of you but I just finally for the
first time watched else yeah I had tears
in my eyes when he went up that
escalator and he's just like oh god
cried speaking of ELF cassava wasn't
have ever elf to myself and yes I did
elf myself when I paid $1 to download
the stupid video kidding me you know
charging people to download the video
I fell for it let's just like down
birdie it's kind of ironic that you
tweeted this question to me would you
let poor Rudolph join in any reindeer
games
I almost tweeted this morning it really
makes me mad the Rudolph never gets to
join and any Ranger games really it
disappoints me it makes me sad but I
feel like if Rudolph wants to join and
Ranger games like why they're not
letting his a busy special because he
has a red nose is it is it well guess
what guess who guided that sleigh that
night and every night Rudolph's you know
why so you got a red freaking nose and I
don't got the reindeers have a red light
up nose do you do you know what am I
getting Ryan for Christmas and what I
recommend any gifts for an avid gamer
I'm a huge fan of scuf gaming
controllers I'll show you actually mine
it's my purple one that I always use a
really cool custom controllers and for
Ryan I got him a few Star Wars cities
I'll see if I can steal some muffins
Instagram and show you I did steal them
and they will be here and if I didn't
steal them then they're not there
Olivia's asking what time gifts do I
enjoy receiving the most during the
holidays umm I know it's kind of crazy
but I started for project for awesome
I'm doing a charity well so if you guys
want to get me a gift that would
probably be the best gift that you could
possibly get like this here and in the
description now he's asked you the top
thing in my Christmas list this year
I know these are probably really really
hideous but they're cheetah hugs
maybe leopard doesn't really matter
because they're amazing el Bali through
he is saying can I have a good picture
of you so I can show Santa what I want
for Christmas um that's a ryan Monson if
I drank all that yerba that I got last
year was that really a year because I'm
pretty sure I ended up drinking that
within six months oops
Paul voltaren says why do you always
look so pretty in your profile pictures
it's a lot of Photoshop so what I do is
I take a photo which normally looks like
this and then I put it through a really
grueling process of Photoshop so it'll
turn out like this Timothy wants to do
it with my most favorite gift that I've
ever received
well I'm gonna show you one that I got
all ready for Christmas this is a little
a little tone pillow Brian got me it's
for Christmas and it's so cute and soft
and it's going to look fantastic next to
my
yo shrine anyway that's it for this
episode of ask IJ be sure to leave your
questions below and maybe I will answer
them the next episode also let me know
what you guys want for christmas or if
you'll celebrate christmas whatever it
is that you celebrate with gifts do you
want don't forget to subscribe and check
out the rest of my youtube channels and
I will see you guys later
hi how's it going Justine you're playing
call of duty black ops 2 I don't know if
you've heard of it it's uh you have it
you're drunk